[Musique]
pearl et papeete est sacripant sont les
amis des enfants vers les côtes est et
sacripant sont des gens charmants sacré
pensionnat vent mais pas toujours un
enfant envoient leurs messages pour voir
si tu n'es sage c'est une chance et du
nord
le
[Applaudissements]
bonjour les peas a mis au jour des
vacances
oh la la fuite puis zik ou faux les
vacances d'hiver
c'est sûrement bon pour la santé mais
cette terrible
bonjour sa fait pas bonjour les petits
enfants sages bouge pas les pattes
alors qu'y at-il de terribles sa trempe
et bien j'étais en train d'expliquer à
l'eau petit ami que les vacances d'hiver
bas c'est bien agréable et
indispensables pour la santé
je vais bien mais par contre c'est
terrible mais pourquoi tu ne t'es pas
amusé ou 6 alors et c'est bien là où les
choses ne vont plus je trouve que c'est
un peu court et n'a pas honte de dire
chaque os répand ont pas du tout les
pépettes puisque c'est la vérité moi il
me faut un certain temps pour me lancer
et quand je commence à bien marcher à
l'école thacker arrivent les vacances et
tout est à recommencer si je comprends
bien tu préfèrerais ne pas avoir de
vacances mais je n'ai pas dit ça oh la
la
rien que l'idée me donne des frissons on
met rien n'est plus beau que les
vacances
rien n'est meilleur pour la santé du
corps et de l'esprit moi j'aime les
vacances seulement pour apprécier les
vacances il faut travailler pour la
santé du corps et de l'esprit tôt rendu
compte que si tu étais en vacances toute
l'année
d'abord tu t'ennuies ray ce qui
amènerait automatiquement à faire des
bêtises
mais ce qui est plus grave c'est que tu
n'apprendrez rien tu ne saurez rien tu
ne t'intéresses rey a rien ta vie serait
un véritable désert mais pas du temps je
jouerai toute la journée dans les bois
avec les petits copains se serait en
effet merveilleux pendant quelques temps
tu en aurais vita c'est alors que ferais
tu mais je lirai impossible parce que tu
ne saurait pas lire et personne ne
saurait écrire y avait pas pensé ballet
encore une fois vous avez raison
il vaut mieux aller à l'école et avoir
des vacances du temps en temps voilà
et là tu deviens de plus en plus
raisonnable ce dont je me réjouis de ce
cas il serait raisonnable de commencer
le palmarès ne croyez pas j'ai mon petit
sacripant ci et pour te prouver ma
satisfaction je te donne les commandes
elle tourne la manuelle merci philippe
fait non j'avais bombe
tu n'es pas le seul à être raisonnable
aujourd'hui un regarde ce beau ciel bleu
voilà qui va vous réjouir je vais déjà
je suis très heureux alors en avant pour
le tour de france
ça y est le voyage est commencé nous
sommes à bure orgeval dans les yvelines
nous avons toute une petite famille qui
nous attend deux garçons et une fille a
repris notamment par fgv aube il y en a
trop je préfère tourner la manivelle
oui eh bien il s'agit de guillaume
vincent et fanny badauds trois russes un
tamm 60 18 630 guillaume à 8 ans c'est
d'abord un sportif il fait de la
natation du judo et il a eu sa troisième
étoile en ce cas c'est aussi un bon
élève quand il se donne un peu de mal
évidemment c'est difficile
oui car il a un nom d' avance vincent
lui à sakho et demi il fait tout ce que
fait guillaume mais c'est plutôt un
poète par exemple à week-end kg mais lui
sont allés chez leurs grands parents
la nouvelle télévision marché sans le
son guillaume penser qu'elle était
cassée
vincent lui a répondu que si elle ne
parlait pas c'est parce que le tue
encore trop petit c'est très mignon jeu
trop mignon alors fanny à 4 ans les
poubelles et je ne m'intéresse pas elle
s'occupe à son petit frère grégoire
s'est elle s'occupe de son petit frère
voir que ce que je dis oh là là elle
fait la cuisine et c'est une passionnée
de télévision ah oui ils sont tous
sympathiques jeu les inscrire dans le
var ailleurs mais c'est très joli balawi
ils ce sont deux enfants qui ont été
sages une fille et un garçon
nom prénom commence par cs comme carole
et simon il s'appelle carole et stéphane
marquis à 8 rue séré-de-rivières 83 400
hier carole assinco elle va à l'école
depuis deux ans et sa préférence va aux
dessins mais elle apprend à chanter de
belles chansons pour sa maman est à la
maison et les sages message mais par
contre il lui arrive de ne pas ranger
ses jouets mange tes fans à deux ans et
demi il est très gentil il va bientôt
aller à l'école
carroll a promis d'être avec lui pour le
consoler s'il pleure c'est très gentil
alors je vous les inscrits ou les le
seul à dijon dans la côte d'or
cette petit garçon qui nous attend sans
prénom
par m comme michel c'est presque de soi
il s'appelle michael been est sans offre
eu de longs geek 21 00 dijon c'est
presque un bébé il n'a qu'un an
ils nous regardent tous les soirs et il
adore notre émission il applaudit
il rigole mais il et coléreux ce petit
bonhomme 1 et parfois il ne veut pas
manger sa soupe
oui mais il est très gentil et très
affectueux bon je l'inscris nous
maintenons a bon dos la manche
cette fois nous allons avoir une petite
fille très bien sacripant très bien elle
s'appelle en effet laurence rochet rue à
juillet 50 de 130 à gond hélas trois ans
sa petite soeur sandrine à un an elle
danse toutes les deux la capucine mais
j'aimerais bien voir ça oui oui notre
petite laurence va à l'école le matin
est en général très gentil mais il faut
que j'apprenne à prêter ses jouets à
sandrine et il faut aussi me promettre
de ne pas lui prendre les siens car ça
c'est très vilain 1
allez je compte sur toi et pour te le
prouver
goethe inscrit
nous sommes à gif-sur-yvette dans les
sommes en haut deux enfants sages
une fille et le garçon par pays et c'est
comme pascal et syrie c'est vrai c'est
bien ça pascal et cyril bordier 27 rue
juliette adam 91 190 gif-sur-yvette
pascal à 6 ans et cyril à trois ans
parce qu'elle fait du judo auditeurs
lipopette j'aimerais bien faire aussi
toi si tu voyais une caravane passe et
tu aimerais devenir chameau pas du tout
à quoi bon alors de toute façon toute
façon il ne s'agit pas de toit n'est ce
pas mais de ces rires et pascal
il travaille bien à l'école et les
gentils avec son petit frère
enfin je l'inscris abbas end dans le bas
rhin
il sert une petite fille qui clôt notre
palmarès son prénom que moi harper comme
patricia
merveilleusement à trouver je dirais
même magistralement merci monsieur
non non non je le pense de ce pas je le
pense alors cette petite fille s'appelle
patricia ackin 7 rue des perdrix no 67
230 benfeld et l'a3 gens elle nous
regarde tous les soirs et à ce moment
précis elle est très très sage sa maman
aimerait qu'elle soit toujours comme
cela c'est difficile mais comme il faut
tendre vers le mieux il faut essayer ma
petite patricia et pour t'encourager
goethe inscrit voilà et maintenant le
grand moment est arrivé
patricia kim de benfeld
pascal et syrie bordier de
gif-sur-yvette laurence rochet dagon
michael been est de dijon carole et
stéphane marquis de hyères fanny
guillaume et vincent bado de bureau par
orgeval aller vite votre part un préposé
les ptt vous y attend pour vous remettre
un colis plein de jouets comme ceux ci
il est temps maintenant aller manger
vota sous peu
bonsoir bonsoir